it's the issue between individuation and
ego and I think your question implies a
confusion of the two I mean we we glory
in the in our individuality our
uniqueness our our specialness but the
ego is something else the ego is
something which seeks to actually
empower itself at the expense of other
people and so you know there has to be a
trade-off I think the glory of Western
civilization is our empowering of our
uniqueness the unique artistic vision
the unique scientific vision the
appalling thing about Western
civilization is how we have you know
taken the worst aspects of dominators
society and institutionalized it and
then passed laws which make it almost
impossible to overturn it so I'm not
preaching any form of an ill fascist
stores communist or otherwise but I do
think you know that we over identify
ourselves with things we over identify
our happiness with objects one of the
great things about psychedelics that is
so corrosive to capitalistic values is
that psychedelics show you that the best
stuff is in your own hand you know
better than walking down Madison Avenue
looking in the windows is sitting in
your shabby apartment on six dried
Graham's looking in the window you know
obviously the world arrives at the
surface of your skin as one thing and
then it enters into channels perceptual
channels of distinction the eyes bring
you some data the ears bring you data
and the and the ideas that within the
brain all these
channels are supposed to be recombined
to give you the original input and
apparently this is culturally a
culturally defined undertaking in other
words when you think you think you're
thinking the way people have always
thought but in fact how people think is
very much dependent on media and
informational biases in the society in
which they were raised I believe most
Western people here themselves think in
other words they hear the equivalent of
a voice speaking in their head and it
speaks their thoughts when you smoke
halfway decent pot or take psychedelics
or something like that you become aware
that the processing of incoming audio
data shifts slightly toward the visual
and you you see what people mean or
their speech seems more colorful it
seems to convey more and I think whether
we process incoming speech by the ear or
by the eye internally is a cultural
piece of cultural conditioning and that
in fact we are in the act of changing
over that you know this generation of
young people who are always dissed as
illiterate are in fact print illiterate
but they know more about electronic
literacy than the people who are
knocking them and their bias is
primarily toward the eye rather than the
year that's why what we really have are
two cultures talking past each other and
I think that psychedelics sort of strip
out culturally conditioned styles of
sensory processing and that what we call
hallucination
are nothing more than our thoughts be
held to some degree and that we're not
used to be holding our thoughts we're
used to hearing our thoughts
[Music]
you
[Music]